una columna de humo sobre kabul luego de
que un drone estadounidense lanzar un
ataque sobre un vehículo a unos 3 km del
aeropuerto según funcionarios de eeuu en
el automóvil se encontraban varios
terroristas suicidas y una gran carga de
material explosivo confiamos en que
alcanzamos con éxito del objetivo las
explosiones secundarias significativas
del vehículo indicaron la presencia de
una cantidad sustancial de material
explosivo estamos evaluando las
posibilidades de víctimas civiles aunque
no tenemos indicios en este momento si
bien eeuu no ha confirmado la muerte de
civiles al menos nueve miembros de una
familia entre ellos seis niños de entre
10 y 2 años habrían fallecido según
apuntó un familiar a la cadena tienen
algunos testigos señalaron que el
estallido se produjo en un barrio
residencial
este es el barrio de coja obra y vivimos
aquí un juguete cayó y golpeó una casa y
seis o cinco personas murieron no tengo
nada más que decir estamos muy
angustiados
este domingo en eeuu el presidente yo
baiden acompañó a los familiares de los
soldados estadounidenses fallecidos en
el atentado yihadista del pasado jueves
en las inmediaciones del aeropuerto de
kabul que acabó con de más de 170
civiles una ceremonia solemne celebrada
en la base de la fuerza aérea de dover
hasta donde llegaron los féretros con
los cuerpos de 11 de los 13 militares
todos ellos jóvenes de menos de 30 años
los 13 miembros del servicio que
perdimos fueron héroes que hicieron el
máximo sacrificio de servicio de
nuestros más altos ideales
estadounidenses y al mismo tiempo
salvaron las vidas de otros nuestra
aplicación sagrada para con las familias
de estos héroes durará para siempre by
then ha repetido que su país se vengará
de los militantes del estado islámico en
afganistán por la muerte de sus héroes